Hey youtubers, it's Charlie this is going to be my Black Panther video
so I'm gonna start with his story in the comics
and then I'm gonna talk about how I think he's gonna be integrated into the Phase 3 movies
Because Spider-man is totally gonna be part of Civil War now
There is a lot of confusion as to how it's going to affect Black Panther screen time so I'll try to explain that too.
I'll be doing videos for all the Phase 3 movies like this
but you guys always send me really awesome requests so keep doing that
I'll include links for some of those other movies in the description bellow
but let's start at Black Phanter's beginning.
In the last 15 years there have been two really awesome retellings of the origins story
there is 'The Client' storyline by Christopher Priest
and then there is the 'Who is Black Phanter?' storyline from Reginald Hudlin and John Romita Jr.
Marvel's recommendation engine always tells everyone to read that second one
the 'Whos is Black Phanter?' storyline, just because it's a little easier for people that have never
read comics before but, if you are really deep in the mythology, if you really like that kind of stuff
the Christopher Priest one is way better.
It just depends on how hardcore you like your comics to be, like if you are a hardcore comic book fan
the Christopher Priest run is probably the one to go with
but if you have unlimited money and it doesn't matter just buy them both.
The first time he appeared was way back in 1966 in Fantastic Four #52
he was the first African-American in comic book superhero.
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby were the ones who so you can totally expect a funny Stan Lee cameo
whenever the Black Panther movie comes in 2018
that seems so far away, I have a feeling at a certain point they will like, digitally map
Stan Lee's face so they can just put him in whatever movies they want.
So after Black Panther appeared in that Fantastic Four comic he just jumped around to a couple diferent titles
until the joined the Avengers in 1968 in issue 52.
So this is a big deal because Ultron appeared for the first time 2 issues later in number 54.
The conection between Black Panther and Ultron is that Black Panther has access to Vibranium
Ultron wants it, although I should say everybody in the Marvel Universe wants Vibranium.
As you'd expect that kinda makes people from Wakanda a little xenophobic.
Not only is he a member of the Avengers, but he's also like their political ambassador too.
What I'm expecting is that the Phase 3 movies will slowly explain this, like, well learn about Wakanda first
like, its a place, well learn vibranium is there, and then we'll start to meet this Black Panther characters.
Fun Fact: Black Panther is not his name. It's just a title given to the current chief of the panther tribe
at any given time, the person that is Black Panther is the panther totem
they form a conection with the panther deity, that gives them their powers.
So whenever you take the mantle, you become the new totem.
On paper, his powers  work a lot like Captain America's, like, he is super strong, super fast
if they were to fight each other on screen, they'd be fairly equal.
It's just that, Black Panther powers come from a mystical source
and unlike Captain America, Black Panther's uniform, his suit, is a vibranium weave.
Imagine having a suit made from the same material that Captain America's shield is made from.
Yeah, it'd be like, having something that is as light weight as street clothes but stronger than Iron Man's armor.
The twist with all his powers though, is that he has to eat a special herb to form the conection
with the panther deity. Whenever he eats the herb, it actvates his powers.
During that Christopher Priest's storyline, he go a bunch new gadgets
and subsequent writers have done the same thing.
Usually when new writers take over a comic they'll give their characters a whole bunch of new toys to play with
Iron Man is the best example of that.
So Black Panther is such an awesome character, why has Marvel waited
this long to introduce him into the movies?
Well there are a lot of reasons, but mostly because of the mystical nature of his abilities.
He also has the conection with Ultron and vibranium, and they are just now getting to that in Age of Ultron
but they haven't done magic yet, they've just cast Doctor Strange, he'll bring magic into the Marvel universe,
so to speak,
and then they can do Black Panther and they can explain all the mystical deity stuff.
Marvel's been playing really safe with the movies, they've just been like
ramping the crazyness up, slowly, so the closest we come to magic so far are the Thor movies
and that's really just super science that looks like magic.
When they do get to the Black Panther movie, they'll probably mostly gonna go with that
Reginal Hudlin and Jonh Romita Jr. run, just because the big villain to that is Ulysses Klaw
and Andy Serkis is playing that character in Age of Ultron.
That doesn't mean that Andy Serkis is going to be the main villain in the Black Panther movie
but it's a pretty safe bet that he's gonna be in it.
The other cool thing about that Hudlin run, is that it deals with the Black Panther lineage
so you get a historical look at all the previous Black Panthers.
Remember, it's a title that gets passed down through the royal line.
In the most current incarnation, Black Panther took the title from his uncle.
There was a run in the comics were he passed the title on to his sister and she became Black Panther.
He's been all over the place. There is even a time when Daredevil had him come to Hell's Kitchen
and gave him, like, his duties as Daredevil fighting crime in and around New York City.
It was like, his time in exhile from Wakanda.
I know that makes everyone wonder, is Black Panther going to guest star in the Daredevil show?
Probably not in season 1, but there is always the chance that he can show up in a cameo in season 2.
So if you are looking for a really easy comic book to read about Black Panther's origin story
just read that Hudlin run.
But really I recommend you also check that Priest run too, just because it's so awesome.
This is a good jumping-off point for the Marvel phase 3 films.
so here is what marvel has confirmed so far:
Chadwick Boseman, playing the character, not going to appear for the first time, officially, until Civil War.
He is not listed on the cast list for Age of Ultron
but Kevin Feige said that we would see him in the Black Panther costume in Captain America: Civil War.
however based on the Age of Ultron trailer it does look like
final boss form Ultron is going to be made of vibranium,
so, I'm interested to see how the movie explains that without explaining Black Panther.
Add to all that now that Spider-Man is going to be appearing in Civil War, in at least a minor role.
The real question is, we don't know how big his role is
and if it's going to supersede the role that Black Panther was going to have.
I don't think that's going to happen. They don't start shooting the film 'til April, 'til after Age of Ultron
comes out, so they still have time to finish rewriting the script.
I think they had a version of the script that didn't include Spider-Man
and once they confirmed that he was going to be in it, they probably changed it again.
Right off the bat they've already said that Civil War the movie is not going to be like Civil War the comic.
So even though Spider-Man was like the linchpin of Civil War in the comics,
that doesn't mean that is going to be the case in the movies.
I think what's gonna to end up happening is that, they'll just bounce a little bit more.
It's still a Captain America movie, so he'll be the biggest character.
Robert Downey Jr. is will be like, the next guy on the list,
and then you'll have all the other characters that Marvel wants to introduce for the first time.
Black Panther being the biggest one.
There is actually a really interesting story about how Captain America 3 turned into Civil War
because, supposedly that wasn't the first idea that they'd had.
Rober Downey Jr. said that, because he wanted to do more movies as Iron Man
but, kinda felt like it was harder and harder for him to quarterback his own films,
the logical next step was to do a team up movie with another big character
and because Captain America was coming up, they had the Civil War story-line, they just settled on that.
Downey did say that he came to Marvel with a couple of ideas
for like, the next step for his character, for the Iron Man character,
so I'm actually wondering what those ideas were, Civil War was just one of the things on the list.
I think the main reason they settled down Civil War is because they could write it to be like
the next logical step for all these characters, given what happens during Age of Ultron.
I'm not gonna get into crazy Age of Ultron spoilers, but Civil War will be the next step from that.
Here is when things get a little timey wimey with the Phase 3 movies:
they are not gonna be linar like, the Phase 2 movies.
Thor 3 and Captain America 3 will both pick up in the moments after the end of Age of Ultron.
But when you look at the schedule, Captain America comes out next year May 2016,
Thor 3 isn't coming until November 2017.
I know it sounds really confusing but those post credit scenes in Age of Ultron will completely set up
all those future films it will completely make sense.
I already made for Thor 3: Ragnarok, so will add a link in the description for that
and for those who are asking, I know a lot of you're confused about which version of Ragnarok it's gonna be.
It's actually the Jack Kirby Ragnarok, its not the Civil War clone Ragnarok.
The difference is that, the Jack Kirby Ragnarok is an Asgard shattering event,
and the Thor clone is a much smaller thing.
Here's my big question for you guys: how do you want Marvel to integrate Black Panther into the Avengers?
Like, how do you want that dynamic to look?
Just remember that all of the films between Civil War and Avengers: Infinity War Part I
are solo titles, so we might not see him in a Avengers' team until that first Avengers 3 film.
But I totally have faith in Chadwick Boseman, he is a great actor, so I think it's gonna be a lot of fun.
I don't think they have officially confirmed a writer yet, but if you watch Arrow
Marc Guggenheim was joking that he wanted to write the screenplay for it.
It was kinda hard to tell whether he was joking or not
but I don't think he would have time to do a screenplay for a movie if he is running a show
that shoots 180 days a year.
So my next Marvel video is gonna be Agents of SHIELD. Big reminder, that comes back on Tuesday,
they are going full steam ahead on Inhumans, so be sure to subscribe to get those weekly videos.
It is replacing Agent Carter, so I'll be doing weekly videos for it again.
While you guys wait for that, you can click here to learn about a maybe Spider-Man cameo at the
end of Avengers: Age of Ultron
Danny Elfman is just writing some music for it so they might have like, a teaser for Spider-Man.
And you can click here for that Thor 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching, so I'll see you guys this weekend, high fives.
Live long and prosper.